drawing it's hard here's a picture I
drew when I was 7 years old it's me and
my dad showering what's the problem I
know what you're thinking endless
potential in this young artist the truth
is I always like drawing I just never
practiced it so in my last video I
decided to try and practice drawing
every day for 30 days and I realized
this is amazing I'm having so much fun
and I could compare the result when I
started to after 30 days and it was a
big difference so it really made me
motivated to keep going and especially
with everyone in the comments being so
supported therefore I continued and
we're at day 100 I drew every day for
100 days so let's look at the result did
we have the same kind of improvement or
have I Peete let's check it out here we
are I'm so excited because I purposely
have not looked at these old ones as
well so we can hopefully experience this
together just for reference this is
where I started off at Day Zero and this
is where we left off at day 30 I really
didn't like these I bought these markers
or pens to fill in I thought it would
automatically make it better but it was
just really hard you know 5 days after I
had done my video I felt like I just
lost sort of what I had gained like I
was so mad about it and I felt like a
fraud like oh did I just trick everyone
cuz I couldn't draw anymore so I kept
going and I try to draw as much as I had
time to do and slowly gain back my
momentum I draw Momo here uh because Mar
wanted me to and she Drew Momo as well I
added it to the
end oh yeah so my favorite rhythm game
is called tuni them sun and they have
these characters that are really
interesting cuz they're so detailed and
fun and weird so I really like drawing
these and I feel like I got the
proportions decent enough which I
couldn't do before so yeah I love
drawing these it's fun to try out
different styles I have not develop my
own and I'm just trying to draw
different things that I see and like as
much as possible and that's what
everyone told me as well the best way to
improve is draw from reference so I drew
these super quick and I felt like they
were kind of fun and weird had to had a
they so sad anime girl anyway I finished
the book I never thought I would so I
bought this new one at a local store and
it was so shitty like the pages are so
flimsy and oh what's this new sponsor
time time to get your wallet gfuel is
launching a new year new you campaign
what are your goals for
2024 maybe you want to get swall get
faked or maybe life got you down and you
just need something else to help you out
introducing the PewDiePie Jal seal
Shaker abs of steel we finally did it we
made the perfect stainless steel cup
this bad boy will keep drinks nice and
cool and fresh just the way God intended
g-fuel to be drunk it is my favorite
g-fuel cup so far it's absolutely
beautiful look at this so yeah get it
before it sells out and remember to use
my code for a discount
$25.99 I always prefer to drink out of
metal cups I don't understand why every
glass is not a metal cup it just makes
more
sense thank you g for sponsoring this
video and helping create the greatest
cup of time don't miss out guys all
right back to the video we'll go through
this quickly I started drawing more
realistic less anime and I drew this one
and my God I was so proud of it I loved
it so much I couldn't believe I drew it
and I felt like yes I did it I drew
something I liked finally it was also
kind of a blessing in a curse because I
would always compare whatever I drew to
the best thing I felt like I drew and it
made me really hate a lot of stuff that
I drew that I don't think was that bad I
don't know just drawing random stuff I
find online on Pinterest and
Google God damn
it I think I was having a bad
day hated it always comparing no that
sh didn't have time to draw that day
interesting cuz I don't remember why
maybe it was cuz I was just doing so bad
who knows uh it's interesting cuz now I
look at this and I can immediately tell
just like what's way off where the head
is too small it's not really balanced
it's the sort of stuff you automatically
pick up when you draw yeah and the eye
is way too high up in comparison you can
see here but anyway it's kind of fun to
go through this to be honest spend more
time on some than others I guess I think
57 was a good
day maybe
not oh yeah so I drew with no reference
cuz everyone like I said everyone said
draw with reference that's the best way
to improve uh to study other forms and
shapes so I wanted to draw without just
to sort of see if if I was improving and
definitely felt like I had so even
though the I are too far apart but hey
could also draw way quicker now as well
but yeah I sort of plowed through this
book so I bought this really big one
like a proper art book instead of a
Sketchbook and I tore off the first two
pages because the paper was so smooth
and I wasn't used to it and it was just
so difficult so no one will know what I
drew but I could actually fit a lot more
into one page which I think was really
fun to just look at
yes I draw cat girlss don't judge me so
I try to do one sort of page per day
which I really like doing try to commit
to a full more full body different manga
and stuff like that you can see how many
attempts it took me to actually draw
something I was happy with I feel like
you draw one thing you like that will
cost you 10 things you
hate I think I use myself as reference
for some of these I know that's kind of
weird I just needed the pose that I
wanted to draw yeah and that one
too I don't want to be an anime girl I
just need the reference oh yeah this one
in the middle is Maria I drew it super
quick I asked her to post for
me it's kind of bad but it's fun to draw
it here we go so I borrowed one of
Marcus's pens the green one it was
really bad in the beginning but I used
the other end of it and I think it was
just too strong I never used a marker
before so I I wasn't sure how to do it
so I bought my own markers just to kind
of try it out and obviously takes more
time to color stuff but I really enjoyed
doing it and it sort of makes them come
to life more and I was trying out
different things sometimes it doesn't
work I drew that one but I was too
scared to actually commit to coloring it
cuz I thought I would ruin it I spent
one day trying to do
green then another they're doing blue
and I try to not waste much time
coloring but then they get really sloppy
and bad so it's
difficult I did yellow which I really
love I was trying out different methods
of sort of how to make it
interesting red and salmon I wanted to
go through every color I had cuz I
didn't have that many
anyway I drew this one and I did it so
sloppily that I felt like I could have
done that better so I really tried on
this one it's quite cute I like it it
reminds me of an anime I watched when I
was way younger I don't remember she had
it was like a redhead girl with a
samurai sword did a purple one these are
very anime drawings you know what I mean
but it's fun to see it in front of you
this is my fortune for the year I got
daichi the best Fortune so prosperity
and wealth to me this year thank you
very much too scared to color this
one
oh my new favorite I love this one this
is on day 84 this is nice to look at I
think it works so it took
me 40 days to feel like I drew something
I liked
again I feel like there's definitely an
improvement I can see it already but it
just took me so many tries and I was
trying different anytime the head is
shaped differently it's like a whole
different ball game if you're not used
to it so I drew from the side for the
first time and as you can see it took a
lot of
tries but I got there okay
there was rep painting here I felt like
I need just needed more practice with
different angle of the head so I try to
do as much as possible yeah different
styles of coloring it's a shame it
bleeds through the coloring I didn't
like that one I tried I just wasn't
happy with it yeah I like that one a lot
too scared to color it don't ask me what
happened here still really struggling to
be consistent with the different angles
of the face messed up the eye I remember
liking this one
one started drawing sad anime girls and
Chainsaw man I love power and uh what's
her name Kenan are so expressive if you
know this scene you know I I remember
reading it I was like I have to draw
that I think it was a bit sloppy but
it's kind of kind of nice could have
done a better job but hey so for day 98
I wanted to draw with you guys so we'll
do that now so I realized I never
actually drwn drawn anything and
recorded it before so it it's a bit
weird but uh this is how I do it I bet
it's
wrong clearly CU I like to do the Eyes
First just cuz they're the most
important and at least at least the
placement of them then I sort of try and
figure out where the chin is going to
end up in relation to everything else
and that does not look right for me as a
beginner this process takes me the most
time but I also think it's the most
important the chin is so difficult it
all has to
work I actually decided to change the
eyes I don't remember why just felt like
they were a bit too
messy that looks better I also decided
to change the body to be front face
instead it just felt more natural and
there we go that's our first sketch so I
colored in with the pen added these
little Frog characters now we can erase
the scribbles which makes it look really
empty I wanted to make the hair gray but
I didn't really have many colors so it
was hard to make it work I tried my best
I feel like the more different tones and
shades the better the More Alive it
looks so I wasn't planning to go this
dark but here we are face is always
scary in my
opinion and then once I'm done coloring
I like to fill in more with the mark uh
I don't know what to call it the pen the
black pen just to give it some more
something I wasn't sure whether to
commit on the frogs but I did
anyway why not so I colored in the frogs
and I decided to add some splasher green
just so the three colors would show up
somewhere on her as well he actually
looks nice I added this circle to make
it more interesting but I don't know if
it was the best idea to be
honest but this is a result
99 I felt like I could finally more
consistently draw different face angles
it didn't take me 600 tries as you can
tell by the lack of
eraser in comparison at least and then
on day 100 I just wanted to draw again
with you guys a little bit of
chainsawman uh cuz I I love these
characters and I think they're so fun to
draw I feel like what I draw usually is
not as good as the reference but hey
it's still fun to look at get
it I love this character so much this
scene was soing
funny best girl easily so yeah that
concludes my 100 day drawing challenge I
owe a huge thanks to you guys for being
so supportive one of the main reasons I
actually decided to keep going cuz I
wasn't planning to do it I remember
asking might say like am I just
embarrassing myself uploading this video
like but everyone was so nice I hope it
doesn't seem like I'm fishing for
compliments but I thank you when I
started going to the gym like 7 years
ago I was not in shape at all but I
remember thinking after I've done it I
was like well I've done it once now I
just got to keep going and then
eventually I'll hit my goal and I'm kind
of keeping the same mentality with
drawing you know I don't know what my
goal is but all you got to do is keep
practicing that's all it takes you know
you don't get better unless you actually
put in the work right I forgot to do the
comparison so this is where I was at 30
days and this is where we're at now
maybe you can't tell a massive
difference but I I I can tell a massive
difference I feel so much more confident
drawing now and I can draw quicker less
attempts and also just to be able to
incorporate color I hope in a year I can
develop my own style more uh but we'll
see you guys then I definitely spent
more time this time around than just 10
minutes a day which is kind of the point
you know it's just a way to make you set
a goal to do something for 10 minutes a
day it's a great way to make you keep
going at it and I was having so much fun
doing it anyway whatever goals you have
I believe in you you can do
it all right I'll see you guys in the
next one
Ro this is what it's like to browse the
internet without using
nordvpn that's right this video is
sponsored by nordvpn there's people
everywhere trying to attack you the
internet gets
restricted but somehow I'm making it
through this you're more unsafe without
it get out way I'm using
nordvpn by using a
nordvpn you can always make sure that
you're protected when browsing online
and don't end up like
they maybe you guys are planning some
trips this
year and you whenever you buy airline
tickets you know they store they store
your information and they might change
the
prices and there's different prices
depending on where on the planet that
you are so don't get price discriminated
just use North VPN
connect who whoa they're going against
traffic and it's that easy
easy always make sure you get the best
price it's practically just MTH you're
making money by buying Nord vbn I'm
trying take advantage of new vpn's New
Year deal right now you get a 2-year
plan you get a huge discount huge plus 4
months additional for free when you use
my link you get the best deal and only
then you get the offer so go to NV
n.com / PewDiePie it's risk it's
risk-free with nor vpn.com money back
guarantee try it out for 30 days see if
you like it then you can change your
mind ah like I should have that's n
vpn.com
PewDiePie get the best deal on the
internet risk-free thank you newvpn for
sponsoring this video